[ __ ] dis
que c'est un tel plaisir de
m'entendre voir Django dire couilles et s'il
te plait irrésistiblement sexy mais tu dis que tu fais un
clown peut faire rire tout le monde
mais peux tu me faire rire continue cet
angle fais moi rire
étranger
excuse moi je '  je suis désolé je ne voulais pas faire
ça je te pardonne tu ris oh
c'est un je ne voulais pas dire sur tout son visage
dépend de l'endroit où tu es dis moi
ce qu'il faisait il a dû faire
pour faire rire certaines personnes  dis-moi, dis-moi,
la pire chose que j'ai jamais eu à faire, c'était
euh
j'avais l'habitude de les faire éclater, je prenais des lunettes et je les
ai sautées sur la tête, vous savez une fois
quand je suivais le programme de la Coupe du monde
en euh Suisse, j'étais à St
Moritz I  jouait à une fête en salle
qui était une fête sur la plage au milieu de l'
hiver pour des gens très riches qui étaient
vêtus de maillots de bain mais ils avaient des
manteaux de vison par-dessus des bases et je
faisais éclater des tasses et l'une d'elles était en
plastique alors quand je  Je l'ai sauté, je me suis
ouvert la tête et je saignais et euh ils
étaient l  rire mais crier en même
temps jungle ou devrais-je dire la jungle
vous dites que le clown est un
fou professionnel il doit être fou et
si vous disiez ce que vous faites qu'est-ce que
c'est à propos de vous avez-vous fait pour
vous rendre fou comme des gars
alors
wow
si je regarde autour de moi tu sais parce que je te l'ai déjà
dit je ne suis pas une personne drôle les
gens sont drôles tout ce que je fais c'est montrer aux gens à
quoi ils ressemblent je veux dire euh je regarde des
choses comme ça
comment tu le regardes  vous savez que les gens le
sont si vous allez chez le jardinier et que
vous restez assis là
pendant une heure et demie, vous pouvez
trouver tout un spectacle, je veux dire que les gens sont
absolument hilarants et j'essaie juste de les
refléter, de leur montrer à quoi ils ressemblent
comme les hommes et les femmes, je vais
vous poser maintenant une question très très importante
décision que feriez-vous oh je pense que
vous devez y aller je ne sais pas Mme Django que
feriez-vous si vous aviez un million un
milliard un milliard de milliards  milliard qui est
des milliards de milliards de milliards de dollars
que feriez-vous  Je veux dire que je ferais mieux d'y aller désolé euh
que ferais-je si j'avais un milliard un
milliard un milliard de dollars
j'achèterais probablement une nouvelle voiture d'
accord tu sais vivant à Amsterdam j'ai eu
une nouvelle voiture une fois pour une pendant cinq jours ça
m'a coûté quarante mille  marks et je l'ai
perdu en cinq jours avec un vol, donc c'était
8 000 marks par jour, ce qui était assez
cher à l'
étranger
tant que je peux respirer tu sais euh
je le faisais quand j'étais plus jeune je gagnais
beaucoup d'argent quand j'étais un homme d'affaires
J'ai gagné beaucoup d'argent et maintenant en Amérique
j'ai un terrain de golf donc j'ai la sécurité Je
veux essentiellement continuer à
transmettre mon message
et mon essence de comédie à tout le monde en
ce moment Je travaille sur un prospect avec
Frederica Fellini qui a été une amie  à
moi depuis longtemps et euh depuis
longtemps, il voulait travailler pour moi et
je veux travailler pour lui en faisant du café ou des
cappuccinos et maintenant il commence
un nouveau projet de film que l'année prochaine je
ferai avec lui  Je serai co-vedette
avec Roberto Benini dans un film sur
ro  mantic lunatics
qui est un projet assez intéressant et
après cela parce que ce nouveau il y a
un nouveau mouvement de clown de bateau qui se passe partout
dans le monde Fellini a décidé de faire
comme Rambo un Rambo deux arc-en-ciel trois
Rocky un droit Fellini va faire des
clowns aussi ce qui est quelque chose que je '
Je lui demande depuis des années de le faire parce que je
pense que le clown a eu une renaissance,
il y a une nouvelle génération de comédiens
et de bandes dessinées au niveau mondial qui est un
style élevé et une méthode de
performance élevée pour les personnes que vous avez des enfants
si votre  les enfants sont allés travailler à la banque
est-il né était-il en
colère oui ou non absolument si je
les amène euh tu sais voler une partie de l'argent
va me rendre un grand service
dis quelque chose en France
non
[Musique]